I'm Cody Bellinger I'm Walker Buehler
I'm Ken tomato
today we're doing a mystery food taste
challenge some of our teammates makes us
some treats and we have to figure out
what it is
whoever guesses the most ingredients
right wins
is it only hotdogs whoo that's a good
question but we can't answer you oh I
would say I'm a little nervous
I have zero trust from Justin Turner
right now but the throw-up already hey
this is like Michelin star wow that was
really good
I'm Gordon Ramsay let's go let's the
rate of these things
holy Sh I'm nervous I really am well you
know yeah there was a gummy bear on
there this is disgusting
I got onion marshmallow jalapeno mustard
there's no mustard there's a hot dog yes
there's popcorn yes there was a gummy
bear yes i'm sriracha yes I can say you
don't have to eat the whole thing
popcorn popcorn what else oh yeah
this mine's gonna be tasty oh I didn't
even eat lunch yet is this gonna ruin
lunch possibly what's this white stuff
is that mayonnaise are these frozen yeah
so hungry
what the Freak is this a chicken tender
no pull
oh we've got I smell relish that's the
boy have a bun and it's a hot dog oh
wait a minute
burger
gummybear all right definitely sriracha
trip optimist how good is that burger
I'm stretching up bet I know that's a
skittle that's a very stale something
like your cinnamon twist or something
that little popcorn thing on the - hey
you got all the ingredients are there
desserts on this that's not a nerd
there's a gummy bear I don't know that
can use hamburger sriracha gummi bear
nerd ketchup you got three what you got
three we're so much better at this game
than you guys you're eating the dippin
dots you want something hey we should
get bonus points cuz we ate our whole
meal I didn't like to pay for mine but
I'm enjoying these now
I don't think I look at hot dogs the
same anymore
you